hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation
part of the agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is bear from biotech a part of
agilent and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
now let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation you may also click
the ask a question box to submit your
concerns
after the completion of the q a portion
of this presentation
our speaker will be available for more
questions in the networking area of the
virtual conference
from 2 to 2 30 p.m eastern standard time
i'd now like to present today's speaker
emily dunkleberger
staff scientist in the laboratory of
chemical physics
at the national institute of diabetes
and digestive and kidney diseases which
is part of the united states national
institutes of health
for a complete biography on dr
dunkelberger please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen emily you
may now begin your presentation
thanks bear thank you for
thank you to biotech for the invitation
to be here today
and thank to agilent for putting on this
event today i want to tell you about how
we
in the eaton group at nih are using
physical chemistry
and a high throughput drug screen to
find a drug to treat sickle cell disease
before i talk about our drug screen
though i want to provide some background
about sickle cell disease sickle cell
disease or sickle cell anemia
is uh known as the first molecular
disease
and that is because in the 1940s linus
pauling discovered that it
was a single point mutation on the beta
globin gene
that causes the disease in normal
hemoglobin or hemoglobin
a there's a glutamic acid on the on the
beta strands
however in sickle hemoglobin or
hemoglobin s that glutamic acid
is mutated to valine this mutation um
occurs in about 1 in 12 african
americans
sickle hemoglobin upon oxygen delivery
to the tissues
form sickle hemoglobin aggregates into
long fibers within red blood cells
those red blood cells sickle they go
from a biconcave disc
shape to a sickle shape and the
resulting cells
are less flexible more rigid
and cause vasoclusion vaso occlusion
causes recurrent pain anemia organ
damage
and early mortality some
groups at nih are working towards curing
the disease through stem cell
transplantation
and gene therapy in our group we are
looking to find
a new drug to treat the disease
currently there's one drug on the market
called hydroxyurea that works in about
50 percent of people with the disease
and in the absence of a cure or a drug
to treat the disease people with sickle
cell disease are left to get blood
transfusions
during painful sickle crises and are
also
given painkillers to just treat the pain
neither of these are great options and
so
we are looking for a new drug
to treat the disease sickle cell disease
is a worldwide problem
in the united states fewer than 100 000
people have the disease so it's
considered an orphan disease
um but there are more than three million
people worldwide primarily in africa and
india who have sickle cell disease
in addition to that between 15 90 of
africans who are born with sickle cell
disease die before the age of five so
this is truly
um it's a problem in the united states
and it's definitely a problem
um elsewhere i want to give just a
very brief timeline of the disease like
i mentioned in the 1940s linus pauline
discovers that it's the mutant
hemoglobin that causes sickle cell
disease
in the 1980s biophysical studies showed
four different ways to treat the disease
with drugs
but then it wasn't until 1998 where one
fda approved drug came to market to
treat the disease and that would be
hydroxyurea
i mentioned groups that are curing the
disease by stem cell transplants
there is a group led by john tisdale in
the national
heart lung and blood institute here at
nih that
has developed a way to cure the disease
and he
he estimates that about about 10 of
patients could be cured by stem cell
transplants
however stem cell transplants can really
only be performed at advanced medical
facilities and it's not
really a feasible option for curing
people worldwide
instead other drugs in addition to
hydroxyurea are needed that can be used
by the millions of people in developing
countries that don't have access
to advanced medical facilities
i mentioned that sickle cell disease is
caused by a molecular mutation
this is a cartoon of a hemoglobin
tetramer
where there's two alpha subunits shown
in green
and two beta subunits shown in blue
the yellow dot on the beta subunits
shows the location of the
negative glutamate in normal hemoglobin
to neutral valine and hemoglobin s
mutation so the mutation occurs on the
surface of the two beta subunits
this produces a hydrophobic a sticky
hydrophobic patch on the molecular
surface
which is what allows sickle hemoglobin
to aggregate
normal red blood cells look like
biconcave discs
the way i describe biconcave discs to my
family is that they look like
little donuts it turns out that
oxygenated
sickle cells also are biconcave discs
however upon deoxygenation
sickle cells take on a variety of
different morphologies
some of them look like pac-man
structures shown at the top of this
slide
some of them look more like amoeba
structures in the bottom left
of this figure um other
other morphologies shown in the in the
middle of this figure
um look more like the sickle shape that
you might expect
most of these sickled cells also have
long spindly bits um called spicules and
that is indicative
of hemoglobin aggregating into fibers
within these cells
upon re-oxygenation sickle cells do
return
to being biconcave disks
however after approximately 40 to 50
oxy reoxy cycles in a sickle cell
they become irreversibly sickled
now i want to talk about sickle cell
disease pathophysiology
in this top figure i'm showing a normal
red blood cell passed through the
arteries
into the capillaries it's in the
capillaries that oxygen is released to
tissues
and in a normal red blood cell it
remains a biconcave disc and is very
malleable
so it can squeeze through the
microcirculation before it continues to
travel throughout the body
however a sickle red blood cell upon
deoxygenation in the capillary
changes morphology it becomes sticky on
the surface
and much more rigid and thus a log jam
can be produced in the micro circulation
preventing cells from continuing
to move through the body blockage of the
microcirculation deprives tissues of
oxygen
and can occur throughout the body
consequences include
severe pain to the point where
it can be called a sickle crisis it can
cause irreversible organ damage and
a shortened lifespan
now i'd like to talk about the kinetics
of hemoglobin aggregation and
the kinetics of fiber formation
what i'm showing is a plot of the
fraction sickled
as a function of time and at the origin
i should have pointed out that this is
the time after deoxygenation what has
been found
through many different studies nmr
studies
microscopy studies is that there is a
characteristic delay time
after deoxygenation in which no cells
sickle
after this delay time the fraction
sickle increases
shown in this red curve as a function of
time
what our group found on the order of 40
years ago or so
is that there is an enormous sensitivity
of these kinetics
on the initial sickle sickle hemoglobin
concentration
such that this delay time is
proportional to 1 over the concentration
of hemoglobin
s raised to the 30th power
this means that even just an 8 decrease
in the concentration of hemoglobin s
increases the delay
time tenfold that's huge
and not seen in many other
proteins now i want to relate these
kinetics
to the pathophysiology it turns out that
it is actually this delay time
that allows the vast majority of cells
to pass through the capillary
before fiber formation so if this is a
sickle red blood cell it becomes
deoxygenated
in the capillary and it's this delay
time that allows the cell to continue
passing through
and not actually get stuck
it is it's really the minority of cells
that sickle during transit and may
obstruct the microcirculation shown
in this bottom cartoon at equilibrium
all cells tickle at oxygen
tissue pressures therefore it's this
delay time that makes the disease
survivable
disease severity is therefore determined
by the relationship between the delay
time
and the capillary transit time
i want to take this idea of kinetics and
pathophysiology
and relate it to a drug treatment
in a minute i'll talk about um ways to
treat
sickle cell disease with a drug all of
which
inhibit fiber formation by one of five
mechanisms
the idea would be to administer a drug
that extends the delay time such that
the cell doesn't sickle in the
microcirculation
as shown in the top cartoon but instead
sickles elsewhere so even partial
inhibition
will be therapeutic because it will
increase the delay time
allowing more cells to escape the
smallest vessels of tissues before
fibers form to sickle cells
and cause vaso occlusion
now i'd like to talk about five
different mechanisms for inhibiting
fiber formation
there are five therapeutic approaches to
treat the disease all by inhibiting
hemoglobin polymerization
the cause of disease pathology i will
briefly mention each of the five on the
slide and then go into
them in more detail later the first
is to induce fetal hemoglobin or
hemoglobin f
synthesis to decrease sickle hemoglobin
concentration
and this is how hydroxyurea the one drug
on the market works
the second mechanism is to increase cell
volume
to decrease hemoglobin s concentration
we've shown this in
our group a few years ago we published a
paper that showed
small molecules and ionophores that
that work in this way the third
mechanism
is to destabilize the fiber by blocking
intermolecular contacts in the fiber
the fourth mechanism is to bind the
find a drug that binds to the r
conformation of hemoglobin to
decrease the concentration of fiber
forming tea conformation
and that is how vaxelator works that's a
drug um
it's it may have come to market at this
point
and the fifth mechanism is to decrease
intracellular 2 3 dpg to decrease the
concentration
of the t conformation of hemoglobin and
that is how the drug metapivot works
and that is currently being tested at
nih in clinical trials
so now i'll go through each mechanism in
a bit more detail
the first is to stimulate hemoglobin f
formation
like i said hydroxyurea works this way
it's been used to increase the fraction
of hemoglobin f
in um in red blood cells
the difference between hemoglobin s and
hemoglobin f
is not in the alpha subunit shown in
blue but rather in the beta subunits so
hemoglobin s
has two beta subunits whereas hemoglobin
f has
two gamma subunits when you have both
types of hemoglobin you're also
bound to get some amount of sf hybrid
it turns out that hemoglobin molecules
with the gamma subunit
rarely enter into hemoglobin fibers
so by increasing the amount of
hemoglobin
f in red blood cells it's
effectively it effectively dilutes the
amount of hemoglobin
s and so there's less hemoglobin that
can enter into fibers
so um this dilution of hemoglobin s
increases the delay time up to a
thousand fold
in people who take hydroxyurea
the second mechanism is to swell red
blood cells to decrease
hemoglobin s concentration
swelling red blood cells increases the
cell volume
and dilutes sickle hemoglobin
so again increasing an 8
increase in volume produces a ten-fold
increase in delay time
which um which is a huge increase
we identified several candidates in our
group such as menensin which is a small
molecule
and gramocidin which is an ionophore but
unfortunately
none of the molecules and peptides we
tested are fda approved at this point
the third mechanism is to inhibit
hemoglobin fiber formation by blocking
intermolecular contacts in hemoglobin
with a small molecule so you could
imagine
that since you could imagine um
developing a small molecule that
attaches to the surface
of hemoglobin and blocks intermolecular
contacts
preventing aggregation however there's a
prohibitively large amount of hemoglobin
in the body
and currently there are no drugs in
clinical trials that are thought to work
in this way
the fourth mechanism is to find a
molecule that binds
to our state of of hemoglobin to
decrease the t-state concentration
before i talk too much about that i want
to first describe what i mean by our
state and t
state oxyhemoglobin is
considered the r state of hemoglobin
upon deoxygenation
the alpha and beta subunits rotate 15
degrees past each other
to become the deoxy state and this new
conformation of hemoglobin is considered
the t state so oxy
goes with our state and deoxy goes with
t state it turns out that
um many studies have shown that it's
only
the deoxy or t-state that fits into the
fiber structure
cartoon bound fibers will be primarily
composed
of t-state hemoglobin so the idea
is to find a drug that shifts the
equilibrium from the t-state to the
r-state
down below i'm showing
oxygen binding curves uh in the
absence and presence of such a drug
the blue curve shows a binding curve
for red blood cells in the absence of
the drug
in the presence of a drug that works in
this way the
the curve shifts to the left showing
that oxygen is held
tighter in the presence of this drug
meaning there's more r-state hemoglobin
around
a reminder this is how vaxelator
works the fifth mechanism
is to decrease intracellular 2-3
diphosphoglycerate
23dpg is a small molecule found in in
blood
and uh it binds to the t state of
hemoglobin so if you can
decrease the amount of 2 3 dpg
it would decrease the concentration of
the t state shifting the equilibrium to
the r state and again
the oxygen binding curve would look
similar to that
in the in the previous mechanism
our extensive research has enabled us to
develop a cellular assay for a
relatively
high throughput drug screen to discover
anti-sickling drugs by
the act by four of these five mechanisms
basically
all except for fetal hemoglobin
induction so now i want to talk about
our assay in more detail
we perform our assay on a biotech
lionheart automated microscope where we
collect bright field images of red blood
cells
currently we have four biotech
lionhearts in our group
this is a photograph of the line these
are all photographs of the lion hearts
of one of the lion hearts in our lab you
can see that the microscope doesn't take
up too much
bench space and there's the computer
that controls the instrument
below that i'm showing a picture kind of
like under the hood
of the microscope we um
we did make one change to the instrument
we
added a 430 nanometer bandpass filter to
the light path
to give us higher contrast deoxy images
in our experiments
in our assay we start out with
oxygenated red blood cells and we
deoxygenate them
it turns out that oxy red blood cells
absorb around 420 nanometers
whereas deoxy red blood cells absorb
around 430 nanometers and so by
adding this band pass filter we get
higher contrast deoxy images
um we um
in order to deoxygenate red blood cells
we flood the instrument with nitrogen
and we can achieve less than 0.3 oxygen
in less than 15 minutes when we when we
turn on the nitrogen source
truly we can get down to about 0.1
percent oxygen
in about 10 minutes which is really
pushing the limits of this instrument it
wasn't meant to do that but it can
and that's awesome for our essay
and lastly i'm showing a picture of
our well plates we do our experiments on
a 384 well plate
we have temperature and humidity control
in our instrument we do all of our
experiments at 37 degrees celsius
and this is the little humidity chamber
that houses our well plates there's it's
kind of hard to see but there's a trough
that goes most of the way around the
well plate that holds water for humidity
and we also use a custom well plate lid
to better control the atmosphere
in each well so prior to doing our
experiments
we send our well plates out to our
collaborators and they pre-spot
um pre-spot the well plates with the
compounds we're planning to test
they send them back to us and then
we get blood from our donors at nih
we are fortunate enough to have a
steady group of people with sickle trait
disease
who are willing to come in week in and
week out and donate
um give their blood um to be part of our
our protocol so we get whole blood
from our subjects and we then
um load columns 1 2
23 and 24 with our positive control
blood suspension
then we load columns 3 and 22 with our
negative control blood suspension
the remaining wells on the plate are
pre-spotted with the test compounds and
we load those wells
with the negative control blood
suspension
then we place our well plate in the
instrument
we incubate for two hours at 37 degrees
celsius in humidified air
and we collect images of all wells every
30 minutes
so we get four images during our two
hour incubation period
then we perform a recharge step all that
means is that we turn on the nitrogen
gas
and fans start to run that circulate the
nitrogen
very quickly throughout the entire
microscope and we run that step for 15
minutes to
hopefully push all the oxygen out and
really flood
flood the instrument with
with nitrogen and after that we we leave
the nitrogen on but we
begin to run our kinetic sequence we run
a kinetic sequence for 12 hours
again at 37 degrees celsius and at this
point we're
at about 0.1 oxygen and we collect
images of every well continuously for
those 12 hours
we start at a1 and go all the way to p24
and cycle back again so
we're able to collect one image of every
well on a 384 well plate in about 15 or
16 minutes
and then we cycle back to the the top of
the plate and
what we end up with is about about 50
images
i think it's 49 images to be exact um
of every single well so we can take
those
49 images and make a movie
to illustrate um how cells sickle so
before we start the video
i want to describe what you're going to
see
um this is a 12-hour experiment
condensed into about 25 seconds
at frame 1 you'll see that most of these
red blood cells
are laying flat on the bottom of the
well plate they all look
like biconcave discs or donuts with a
pretty transparent center and
a dark outer ring you might notice that
some of the cells
do look like ovals um
those are cells that for whatever reason
um aren't laying flat on the well plate
they are not sickled
but they are they're laying on their
side on the well plate
once the video starts you'll pretty
quickly see that the cells
get darker when they get darker that is
indicative of
the start of deoxygenation and then you
will see cells
um throughout the field sickle such that
by the end of the
movie approximately 90 of the cells in
this field will be sickled
so at this point we can go ahead and
start the video
please
um so you noticed that by the end of
the video most of uh the red blood cells
had sickled
some of them may have looked like
pac-man figures some of them
most of them had spicules and were
in a sickle shape
the goal of our assay is to be able to
plot fraction sickled versus time
plots for each well and to do that we
had to somehow quantify
quantify sickling
15 years ago or so we um
identified three different metrics that
we could
measure in our images to identify when a
cell sickles
the first is the cell area the cell area
decreases
when cells sickle the second is
eccentricity eccentricity
increases when cells sickle and the
optical density ratio
of the inner part of the cell to the
outer part of the cell decreases when
cells sickle
in this figure i'm showing pairs of
images
of a single cell the image on the left
is a
biconcave is the cell when it's a
biconcave disc
and the image on the right is the same
cell
after cycling so um you can see each
pair
of cells pair of images for a given cell
and below each pair of images
um is a kinetics plot showing in blue
the cell area as a function of time in
green
is the eccentricity as a function of
time and in red is the density ratio as
a function of time
it's the time at which these three
metrics change
in the direction that they're supposed
to that we call
the sickling time for a given cell so we
can count up the number of cells that
that trap that are sickled at a given
time and plot the fraction sickled
versus time
about five years ago we started to use
machine learning to analyze our images
we are doing experiments on 384 well
well plates and we're collecting about
50 images per well
what that means is that we end up with
almost 20 000
images for a single well plate
that's a lot of images and so we needed
to come up with a really smart way
a really fast way of of
classifying cells so to do that
we turn to machine learning what i'm
showing
in this figure are just screenshots of a
training session i did where i looked at
images from a given experiment and
identified by eye cells that were
sickled shown
in red versus cells that were by concave
shown in blue
the machine learning algorithm then
takes my assignments
and calculates 12 different metrics
including
area density eccentricity but also
others
to determine the characteristics of each
of those two classes of cells
then we make a model based on those
metrics
and we use that model to analyze data
sets to individually determine
how many cells are sickled in a given
image at a given time point
and this is what the controls look like
for our for our
drug screen just a reminder we're
starting with oxyhemoglobin
upon deoxygenation it becomes
deoxyhemoglobin
this is a picture of our 384 well plate
these are images from
negative control at time zero versus
the end of our experiment when greater
than ninety percent of cells have
sickled
and then this is a fraction cycle versus
time plot the negative control is shown
in blue
and the positive control shown in purple
the negative control
is an average of 28 wells in columns 3
and 22
shown with the standard deviation error
bars
the positive control also has
contribution from 28 wells and the
error bars are there they're just quite
small
the goal of our drug screen
is to find candidate drugs that decrease
that increase the delay time or decrease
the
the fraction sickled and we want to find
a candidate drug
that um has a fraction sickled
um below that that maintains
a fraction cycle below this therapeutic
threshold this therapeutic threshold is
about 70
relative to the negative control and
that is something we calculated in our
group
a while ago i'll explain where we get
that in a minute
or on the next slide
this is a plot of fraction sickle versus
time
for three three theoretical calculations
that we did the first
shown in blue the blue continuous curve
is the theoretically calculated
kinetics curve with a standard deviation
shown in the blue dashed lines
this curve is for sickle trait blood
that is about 65
hemoglobin a and 35 hemoglobin s
this is um this is um
basically equivalent to our negative
controls in our assay
there's a less severe form of sickle
cell disease called sc disease
where red blood cells are made up made
up of about 50
hemoglobin s and 50 hemoglobin c
um for for us to think about it
we we know that hemoglobin c is
similar to hemoglobin a and that it
doesn't enter fibers
so to get this green calculated curve
we substituted 50 of the hemoglobin
in the trait distribution to with
hemoglobin a and that theoretically
calculated kinetics curve is shown in
green
with um error bars
shown in the dashed curves there
is another form of sickle cell disease
that is considered benign
oh i should i should mention that if we
were to find a drug
that has kinetics similar to the green
curve
we could pretend we could call it a
potentially therapeutic
um compound because we know sc disease
is
much less severe than sickle cell
disease
the third the third curve
is representative of um benign
this benign disease called sickle cell
disease with hereditary persistence of
fetal hemoglobin um
globin is the the form of heat of
hemoglobin found in fetuses
and it persists through about one year
of age
after that normal hemoglobin is produced
but um in in the case where
fetal hemoglobin persists into adulthood
those with this form of the disease
um rarely suffer any of the health
consequences
that those people with sickle cell
disease have so
in this calculation we replaced 30
percent
of the hemoglobin in the in the trait
distribution with hemoglobin f
and the result is this red kinetics
curve so if we were to find a drug
that is similar to
this red curve kind of compound that has
kinetics similar to this red curve
it would be a potentially curative
compound
so a couple years ago we were provided
with a collection of 12
657 compounds that have been previously
tested in humans
our research goal is to discover a new
use for an old compound
because any drug that shows
therapeutically significant anti-cycling
activity in our screen at concentrations
that are known to be non-toxic in humans
can be tested by others in research
clinical trials at nih
on sickle cell subjects in this figure
i'm showing
a map of the well plates that we
received the red wells
are the edge wells we omitted those
results from our data to
avoid any edge effects the positive and
negative controls are shown in orange
and gold on both sides of the plate
and then the green wells are the wells
that were pre-spotted with
test compounds we performed our initial
screen at 10 micromolar in triplicate
and within each triplicate we used blood
from three different donors
i want to go back real quick to talk
about the controls in our experiment
the negative controls um
were done in physio the negative
controls are made of
above blood suspension and physiological
buffer ph seven four
three hundred milli osmols and at the
end of the experiment most of the cells
are sickled there are very few biconcave
discs
our positive control is
a blood cell suspension in low
osmolarity buffer
in this case the ph is still seven four
but
um the buffer is at about 180
milliosmoles
so going to a low osmolarity buffer
swells and spheres cells
you can tell that the cells in this
image
um are darker
have darker centers than biconcave disks
there are very few by concave disks
um in this image and that's indicative
of an increased cell volume so
that's we've found that going to a low
osmolarity buffer for
positive control is a very robust and
reliable
positive control in our assay
so the first thing we do after analyzing
our data
with machine learning is we create what
we call dot plots
dot plots are a map of our 384 well
plates where each well is color coded
based on the fraction sickled relative
to the average negative control for the
well plate
as a result the positive controls end up
being shaded in purple because
they have very low fractions sickled
relative to the negative control
the negative controls are shaded in
black and then all of the
compound wells are shaded according to
um according to this legend
and we create dot plots for every frame
in our experiment i've just grabbed one
this is frame 20 from a given experiment
you can see that at frame 20
most of the wells have
pretty high fractions cycled relative to
the control but there are three wells
that stand out
and i want to um
look at now go go to the kinetics for
one of these wells so i
chose o18 to look at the kinetics for
on this plot i'm showing the fraction
cycle versus time
for a given well on this plot
i have i've plotted the average
negative controls for the three plates
in the triplicate the green plate the
blue plate and the red plate
we also plotted the average positive
controls
um and these dashed curves in the in
green blue and red
and then plotted the single well
kinetics for o18
for the three three wells in the
triplicate and you can see
that the kinetics for o18 are very
different from
that of the negative control
so we generated dot plots and we
generated kinetics
for kinetics plots for all 12 000
some odd compounds in our initial screen
and we categorized
our results
by identifying three different three
different groups
of inhibitors the first is the complete
inhibitors
the second is the partial inhibitors and
the third are the lysis inhibitors
the complete inhibitors are those that
prevent sickling
for the duration of the experiment so
you can see
those kinetics represented by this well
b7
the negative controls are highly sickled
by the end of the experiment but the
single well kinetics
look pretty much like the positive
controls
and it's important to always go back and
look at the actual images and not just
the kinetics to make sure that the
kinetics are really
representing what's going on and in
doing that we can see that
most of the cells are by concave discs
at the beginning of the experiment and
still by concave discs at the end
the group of partial inhibitors um
a rep a representative
well of from the partial inhibitor
classes shown here in h21
and you can see that there is some
sickling in the single well kinetics
relative to
the negative control kinetics and that
is apparent in the images as well so
this is an image from age 21 at the
beginning of the experiment where cells
are biconcave discs
and at the end there's approximately 30
to 40 percent of cells that are sickled
so this is a partial inhibitor it's
uh we still consider it a hit
and the third class are is the lysis
inhibitors
um if we had only looked at the kinetics
we might say oh
this is this compound in well g4
is is a partial inhibitor maybe even a
complete inhibitor
but after looking at the images it's
clear that something else is happening
besides
besides just in complete or partial
inhibition
at time zero we can see that there are
very few biconcave discs in the image
meaning that
this compound whatever it is has
swelled and even sphered the red blood
cells even at early times at late times
you can see again that there's no cells
no sickled cells in the final or maybe
very few
sickle cells in the final image so
we found a um
we found a lot a large amount of
compounds
that seem to inhibit sickling by lysis
or at least by swelling and sphering
cells
we do understand that it's important not
to give
um a drug to someone with anemia that
a drug that causes hemolysis to someone
with anemia
but we do want to further pursue these
compounds at lower concentrations to see
if
they have an inhibitory but not
lysis effect on red blood cells
so after looking at the dot plots the
kinetics and the images we actually
wanted to find or want to
use a mathematical way to identify
or to define a hit and we did that using
svd or singular value decomposition from
our svd analysis
we ended up finding 335 hits from our
initial screen
and we defined a hit as having
a delta over sigma value of greater than
three
on at least two of the three plates that
we tested in the triplicate
svd is a powerful mathematical method
for averaging data
and eliminating noise singular value
decomposition represents a set of data
so in this case a 380 384 sickling
curves
as the product of three matrices the u
matrix the s matrix
and the v matrix so the data including
the noise is exactly reproduced by
the matrix product u by s by v
so as as judged by the magnitude of the
singular values the complete set of 384
sickling curves for a single plate can
be quite
well represented by the single average
sickling curve u1
with an amplitude v1 for the curve from
each well so what i'm showing here are
three
more compounds from our initial screen
the first two we consider partial
inhibitors and therefore potentially
therapeutic and the third is a complete
inhibitor which is potentially curative
but in the top panel i'm showing the raw
data where the continuous curves
are the single well kinetics and
the positive and negative controls are
also
on the curves and dashed lines with
their error bars
the bottom panel is the u1
by s1 by v1 svd curves
and you can see that the svd analysis
truly represents the raw data but it's
it's a bit cleaner and the noise has
been eliminated
um the value of v1 for a well containing
a candidate drug is compared to the
to the average v1 values of the negative
control wells
and if the v1 for the compound is
uh lower than the average v1 for the
negative control by more than three
standard deviations we consider it a hit
oops so what we found in our initial
screen
is 267 compounds that showed
therapeutically significant anticycline
activity
and 62 compounds that caused hemolysis
in total our research discovered 335
compounds to test
in a just response screen
so that was the next step um this figure
is a map
of what our well plates look like for
the dose response screen
again the edge wells are shaded in red
we omit that data
we have our positive and negative
controls on both sides of the plate
and then our dose response screen was
performed at
nine concentrations shown by the gold to
green gradient
for every compound so we tested
um we tested all 335 compounds from 10
micromolar down to one nanomolar
in triplicate and again performed the
drug screen
used used three different donors blood
within a within a triplicate
these are some of the raw data from
our dose response screen these are
sickling
for each of these three compounds i'm
showing sickling kinetics at 10
micromolar
the continuous curves again are the
single well kinetics
and the dashed curves with error bars
are the positive and negative controls
we got sickling kinetics for obviously
for
all nine concentrations for every
compound and
to better compare what was happening at
each concentration
we plotted the v1 of the compound
relative to the v1 of the control as a
function
of concentration shown here in the
bottom panels
so if the ratio of the fraction circled
the compound
is small compared to the control then
um we consider
um we consider the compound to have some
should be showing some inhibition at a
given concentration so for this first
compound
you can see that the ratio at least on
the green plate and the red plate
are very small around point five
and this ratio approaches one at lower
concentrations
for the second compound it looks like
all three plates in the triplicate have
a ratio close to zero
at 10 micromolar um the ratio
is small also at three micromolar and
then approaches one
at higher concentrations for this last
compound
it's a little bit unclear what's
happening at higher concentrations
but there does seem to be a trend
in the fraction sickled of the compound
relative to the control
such it approaches one at lower even
lower concentrations so
we used svd on all of these data and
were able to get these plots
we ended up fitting those those
data and calculating an ac 50 for each
compound
this particular compound we found to be
an inhibitor
at about 10 micromolar this particular
compound
shows inhibition down to three
micromolar
and after looking really hard at the
images
from this compound we've we found that
there was
hemolysis at higher concentrations
but at lower concentrations we found
that this compound
sphered swelled and sphered cells and
and inhibited sickling
but didn't actually lyse the cells so we
consider this compound a lysis hip but
also
it's an inhibitor down to about 30
micromolar
our dose response screen of 335
compounds at 9 concentrations resulted
in 138 hits
at concentrations of 10 micromolar or
less
96 compounds show therapeutically
significant anti-sickling activity
42 compounds caused hemolysis and so in
total
138 compounds were considered hits
and de-anonymized for future testing
this de-anonymization happened this
spring and so
it has opened up a lot of reading and
more experiments for us to do
with that i would like to conclude and
briefly mention some of the future
directions that we're taking
sickle cell disease has been extensively
studied since the 1940s
and it's considered the first molecular
disease unfortunately though there's
only one single partially successful
drug
that can be taken to treat the disease
our research uses the biotech lionheart
automated microscope
and it the microscope allows us to
screen thousands of compounds
in a given week our assay identifies
uh compounds that inhibit polymerization
and sickling which is the cause of the
disease pathology
recent de-anonymization has allowed us
to further test hit compounds in a whole
blood assay
which is an ongoing project in our group
we just started this a couple months ago
not very long ago
and our assay is also being used
currently on mice with sickle trait and
sickle cell disease as well as an
emitted pivot research clinical trial at
nih so
all this is to say we have a lot of
ongoing
experiments with that
i would like to
thank my advisor at nih bill eaton
and my colleagues belle who troy quan
and eric
we each bring something unique to the
table some of us are
physicists who do computer simulations
and theoretical calculations and some of
us are experimentalists
in the lab so i would also um
so we work together to um
to get this we we had to work together
to get the stroke screen off the ground
um i'd also like to thank a couple
people at biotech
diane and mega who have been an
invaluable resources for me
they've they helped a ton in getting
the lion heart just the way we needed to
be to
best work for our essay so with that
i will be happy to take questions
all right well thank you emily for the
informative presentation
uh we'll start the q a portion of the
webinar i just want to remind people
that if you
have have a question that you haven't
asked you can do so right now
if you click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
uh looks like we have a couple so let's
get started our first question
is why did you use sickle trach blood
for this drug screen
yeah so um i think i briefly mentioned
that we use sickle trait blood
in our drug screen rather than sickle
blood from sickle cell
rather than blood from donors who have
full sickle cell disease
and the reason because um we don't want
someone with anemia to come in week in
and week out to be giving blood
for our essay this is this is a project
that's been
ongoing for um i think
at least a decade now and so at nih
um it's it's been really helpful to
have a steady stream of donors here at
nih who are willing to come
once a week every week for years at a
time to give blood so
we wouldn't want to ask someone with
sickle cell disease to do that
people with sickle trait um don't really
suffer any of the
negative health consequences of those
with sickle cell disease
um in addition to that sickle trait
blood is a little bit less than me
to use in an assay so that's why
we are using sickle trait blood at this
point
um see our next question is do you
expect any differences
in the assay or results when switching
from using sickle trade blood to sickle
cell blood
um the answer is yes so
one of the goals of our in the near
future
is to actually move from using
dilute sickle trait blood to whole blood
and then
moving from whole blood from sickle
trait donors to whole blood from sickle
cell
donors and we do expect some differences
the primary difference is that we expect
blood
from sickle cell donors to sickle much
faster
in our assay there is a lag
in sickling that delay time
is on the order of 100 to 200 minutes or
so
we expect sickle cell blood to sickle
much faster just because
um all of the hemoglobin in sickle cell
blood is hemoglobin s whereas in sickle
trait
blood the proportion of hemoglobin is
about 55
hemoglobin a which doesn't sickle and 35
hemoglobin s
which does sickle
we've got another one here um do any
compounds you test to do anything to
change
the cellular morphology outside of what
you're used to seeing when cells sickle
and how does your machine learning
algorithm account for those changes
um yeah so some of the compounds we
tested
do change the cellular morphology
outside of
um just forming biconcave disk
or sickled cells so i kind of alluded to
that
in my example of the lysis inhibitors
we did notice that that particular
compound
caused cells to sphere immediately
after loading the plate with red blood
cells
we also noticed that some compounds to
cause
some compounds cause crenation in our
red blood cells
so created red blood cells
are are biconcave discs and that they
have a somewhat transparent center but
then they also have
kind of a bumpy surface to them it's
very easy to see
in our in our images when that happens
and um so yeah so we had to
really watch out for that we even though
we use machine
learning to analyze all of our images we
actually do go back and look at just
about
every every single well in
every single plate and so we've looked
at a lot of images
to make sure that the machine learning
algorithm really
and the resulting kinetics curves really
represents what's happening
so our machine learning algorithm
is always a work in progress we are
constantly trying to
make it better and make it such that it
better defines
um the cell shapes that we're seeing and
we currently don't have
a great way to identify
good cells but it's something that we're
constantly working on
let's see we have another one here you
mentioned using this assay to test mouse
blood
can you talk a little bit more about
those experiments
yeah so one project that i was involved
in
last year was
a project where mice were fed either
a normal diet
or an extremely low iron diet
and it's thought that um
in the presence of a low it's not that
mice on a low iron diet
will be less prone to sickle cell
disease so
my collaborators were in charge of the
mice
and feeding the mice and treating the
mice and
then they gave us these these mice were
bred to have
human hemoglobin s in all of their red
blood cells
and so they were
transgenic with human hemoglobin
fed either an iron rich or an iron
depleted diet
we received the blood in our experiment
in our lab
and then we did this same assay where we
loaded the well plate with this mouse
blood and
measured the sickling kinetics and found
slight differences
in the sickling times for mice on the
iron
rich diet versus mice on the iron
depleted diet
all right well looks like we have time
for one more question
what are some of the metrics other than
cell area eccentricity and density ratio
that you're able to measure using your
machine learning assay platform
yeah to be honest
i could not list all 12 of the metrics
that we're currently using
but i know that one of the metrics that
is currently used is the perimeter of
the cell
so the
the machine learning algorithm is um is
set up
to measure the number of pixels along
the edge of the cell
and there's a range in which
there's a um a range in pixel number
that we think
a normal cell a normal biconcave disc
cell
has versus that of a sickled cell versus
that of a crenated cell so you could
imagine if you have
a circular a circular cell by concave
disc
it has x number of pixels on the edge
um that forms the perimeter but a cell
that is created and has lots of little
bumps on the edge
would actually have a larger perimeter a
larger number of pixels making up the
perimeter of the cell
such that that would be a useful metric
for identifying if a cell
is larger than a normal biconcave disk
so um i know the perimeter is one of
them
um i would have to probably look up what
some of the others are so
i hope that created that a little bit
well
thank you for your time today and your
important research
uh before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us
and any questions submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of your registration
if you have any other questions for
emily today please join her
in the networking area of the virtual
conference starting in a couple minutes
and going um until let's say 2 30 p.m
eastern time if you have any biotech
specific product questions
please visit us at the biotech booth
found in the exhibit hall
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand through july of 2021
so until next time thank you and goodbye